separatist celebrate near the entrance
to the city of Aden it's believed the
UAE conducted an airstrike targeting
government positions that allow the
separatists to retake territory they'd
lost two saudi-backed government forces
24 hours earlier the separatists pulled
in troops from the front lines fighting
the Houthis we managed to retake all of
Aden and we are now clearing the city of
sleeper cells
we urge all residents in every district
to hand over all elements from those
sleeper cells they are invaders
we don't want traitors among us
separatists from the southern
transitional council a part of the Saudi
UAE coalition that's fighting against
the Houthis but in a dramatic twist less
than three weeks ago
they took over the city of Aden the seat
of the saudi-backed internationally
recognized Yemeni government on
Wednesday its port is recaptured the
port city both sides say they're now in
control the violence has exposed an
apparent rift in the Saudi UAE coalition
with each country backing opposing sides
in southern Yemen Saudi is caught in
this awkward limbo whereby it does not
necessarily want to discard its alliance
with the UAE but it knows that the
famine divides then the humiliation will
be on Saudi Arabia and not necessarily
on the UAE Saudi Arabia knows that if a
man splits between north and south south
is likely to be pro UAE north is likely
to be pro Iran Saudi Arabia is the party
that loses
government forces say they're sending
reinforcements to Aden 60,000 people
have left the city but tens of thousands
remain in harm's way as the fighting
intensifies Victoria Gaytan be al
Jazeera